Today's Sandy Speaks is going
to focus directly
on my white people.
But what I need you
to understand
is that being a black person
in America is very, very hard.
OFFICER BRIAN ENCINIA:
I will light you up! Get out!
-SANDRA BLAND: Wow.
-Now!
SHANTE NEEDHAM:
Sandy called me,
let me know
that she had been arrested.
How do you go from...
SHARON COOPER: ...failure
to signal a lane change...
SHANTE:  ...to dead in jail
by alleged suicide?
GENEVA REED-VEAL:
I believe she let them know,
"I'll see you guys in court,"
and I believe they silenced her.
R. GLENN SMITH: Do I think
this jail had anything
to do with her death?
No.
But moral responsibility-wise?
Absolutely.
-PROTESTERS: Sandra Bland!
-CHANT LEADER: Say her name!
ALL: Say her name! Say her name!
Say her name! Say her name!
Say her name!
SANDRA: If we want change,
we can truly make it happen.
Sandy speaks!